josh duhamel the actor Vikings fan
joining us he's got a new movie spaceman
that's not why we had Josh on but he has
the story of a bill spaceman Lee
following is released by the Montreal
Expos so Josh plays the role of space
man now available in select theaters
google play Amazon gosh joining us from
London bad news yesterday with your
Vikings with Teddy how did you get the
news Josh wait a second I want to hear
more about which is growing okay have
you ever had a hernia or a pulled groin
John I have actually pulled both of my
groins when I was playing hockey as a
kid and I'll never forget it was on my
birthday and I had to walk around on
crutches for like two weeks a--'s I was
skidding into the boards and just before
I got there I fell both my knees split
and I literally had groin injuries ever
since Oh fritzy I can I can relate I
thought I really have anything sticking
out from it yeah but you were an athlete
Oh Josh well if you can call it that a
we've seen we've seen the football
highlights because you've shown them to
us oh I could send you more like vision
maybe I should set up a Zimmer yeah
maybe zimmer can use use it was in my
quarterback might need some help over
there the 43-year old backup quarterback
from under state university I like it
might not look so bad that would be your
next movie is it sort of like George
Plimpton when he tried out for the
Detroit Lions that you could be you know
the paper the paper Viking there how'd
you get the news yesterday in London
well i got i guess i got a text i got a
text only remember who and then i
started calling around looking out of
the websites and you know try to figure
out what exactly happened and ended up
listening to Zimmer's press conference
uh and yeah sure enough he's out he's
out looks like he's gonna be out all
year oh yeah and it's not good it's not
good i'm not entirely confident guys we
got back them up Sean Hills serviceable
stava is a little bit unproven but I
don't know you know do we go out and
it's somebody to look at Manziel no no
good no I mean the drug dealers around
the office of neutral no good you got
Michael Vick Mike Glennon may be Mark
Sanchez Josh McCown I mean it's not
exactly murderers row here for you josh
i like i like i like the Glennon kid so
do i if you up well regret no you're
gonna have to trade for Kaepernick
Sanchez Glennon Geno Smith might get
released you might have to train you
know I think you're going to give up
something to get some kind of quality
back up here yeah and you thought that
this was the year right you thought
maybe maybe you're super bold you know
dark horse yeah I figured that we were
we were definitely you know last year
ended it was it was it was pretty bad
the way it ended last year but you know
we we had that game one against yellow
we beat them up and down the field all
game and it was a couple's flute plays
and that Miss kick by Walsh you know
sent us packing and that's sort of
typical Vikings you know I switched in
the playoffs but I feel like this team
is different I feel like Zimmer's got
these guys believing they can actually
win and it's it's a it's a tough blow
but you know what I think what the
defense as tough as they are they're
gonna be able to stay in games now it's
inaudible and not when you get a
quarterback you can just sort of keep
the ship righted you know not make dumb
mistakes what are you doing in London
shooting transformers five oh my god
yeah we're in Wales last week it's funny
because went to Wales which is beautiful
desolate a lot more sheep than actual
human beings in Wales I don't you know
that I did not and no it's it's
beautiful uh and then we bet not we've
drove into London and it was you know a
holiday weekend and London was just
popping it was crazy so it was we saw
two different ends of the spectrum
interrupt two hours and so we're gonna
be here for what a month i got my wife
out here with me i got my little boy
they were just going to be you know
living
as the bits do for the next month or two
who's in transformers five well it's see
Wahlberg is back Anthony Hopkins has a
pretty cool part in it uh Laura haddock
who's a Brit herself um god I don't like
I can't remember the other guy's name
which civil among really big actor I
can't remember his name so we'll just
move on Paulie and I ball gear on Google
time Google that so I look a Josh got me
know Louise in a movie with could well I
don't have any season I thought do I can
really tell what I'm doing from day to
day on this movie could you take Walter
can Josh could you take Wahlberg could I
take him on what fight you know I'm
talking about if it's go time oh you
know I've got a lot of reach on him I'm
pretty I'm taller than him but he's a
scrappy little dude he's got a lot of
flight experience you know it would have
to be something where I'd have to train
for a little bit just to hang in there
because you seem I grew up in Boston man
yes those guys as it would with you know
a lot of older brothers so he's probably
had a lot more experience but I wouldn't
count me out yeah I think he'd fight
dirty too yeah if he got you to the
ground in trouble I don't think it would
ever come to that point he's a pretty
good good just in case it goes that's
all just I'm trying to start selling
here reporter sort of like sort of like
rock and Vin Diesel yeah what's going on
I said I have no idea man I have no I
read something about it I guess I could
ask hi Reese I know Tyrese what Deb you
ever had one of those moments when
you've been on a movie set where you
wanted to beat up a fellow actor oh
never almost never one time and it was a
domick thing because we're actually
doing a fight scene where it was he and
I were going at it was on Las Vegas and
we were we had the scene that we're
pushing each other background and and he
pushed me and I pushed back and I
accidentally grabbed this tie
and and then we did another take and I
actually grabbed it again I sweatin me
too but he started to get pissed so the
next time you came back and pulled on my
time so then it became like these two
guys pulling on each other's ties in the
scene and then you know they had to
separate us and you know you got Hurston
called his agent and wanted to leave but
it was you know oh it all turned out
okay with friendship wait who was it I
can't say look on the poly look on the
IMDb here Johnston who he's in a movie
with and who he got into a fight with uh
no I don't ever show up it you know was
it was it was stupid that's the closest
we ever got via this bill spaceman Lee
movie did you hear from it was spaceman
Lee involved in this movie yeah he was
involved quite a bit he came to the set
I talked to him the most i thought you
know he doesn't have a cell phone or
anything so you have to like be up to
schedule a time to call and he'll go to
some pay phones up in Maine or Vermont
or wherever he's at at the time and call
you from from some payphone and so that
was the first time I talked to talking
about 20 minutes and you know for the
life of me the guy is he's brilliant
first of all he speaks you know he'll
talk about whatever he reads non-stop
and you know you'll go off in these
crazy tangents I just remember us
talking about wine and you know cut yeah
just cut your head off and let your body
do the talking and that's really the way
he lived his life was you know he just
sort of acted first and paid the
consequences for it later and that
ultimately got him thrown out of
baseball because he was if you by Major
League Baseball is is an outlier a guy
who who was anti-establishment in a lot
of ways and admitted you know so talk
openly about his you know marijuana use
and drinking while he was playing
everything else and they hated that but
the fans of the media loved him so he
became an iconic figure in Boston and
then in Montreal and then ultimately got
released from Montreal for standing up
for one players under
went across the street and drank a few
beers during the game in his uniform and
said call I'll just call me if you need
me because you just need a release one
of the guys and then the next day they
just released him and that's sort of
where this story begins is him trying to
get back in and realizing he's never
going to get back in and start planning
he's barely except in Canada it's great
you know I really am proud of the movie
it's we shot it for nothing in 13 days
and you know it's it's it's a really
cool little movie about this guy who's
trying to figure his way after after the
game you love up in behind the movie is
space man starring a josh duhamel about
Bill spaceman Lee it's in select
theaters google play Amazon and directv
we noticed that jay mohr and I poon
don't forget I in itunes jay mohr was in
one episode of Las Vegas did you get
into a fight with jay mohr no but I
actually uh broke up if I would walk on
the one said he was on an effort few
days I remember he got in you got into
her some of the producers and I sort of
stepped in on his behalf go figure yeah
but anyway it was it wasn't Jay and I
now ah all right well good luck with the
Viking search for backup quarterback
tell fergie ferg that we settle oh and i
will have fun over there and introduce
yourself to your cast just get to know
him a little bit better okay Josh you
acclimated back to the States after
being over in Brazil yeah it was only an
hour difference but that it took a
couple of days but yeah it's fine I'm
glad to be back it was a good trip to a
job thank you John why thank you buddy
uh have fun over there safe travels all
right be good boy I it's josh duhamel
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you